[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEEVANA HEGDE: Hi, everyone.
I'm Jeevana Hegde.
JOLENE TEO: And I'm Jolene Teo.
JEEVANA HEGDE: And we're
both customer engineers
at Google Cloud.
And we're excited to share with
you all about this new series
of videos that we are
launching, specially
catered to help startups.
JOLENE TEO: Our mission
begins with you.
And we're highly
invested in helping
you to build your business
with the innovative technology
and holistic support
from Google Cloud.
Be it whether you're in the
early days of product market
fit or you have just received
your next round of funding,
we are here to help you grow.
JEEVANA HEGDE: Keeping
our focus on startups,
we are creating a series of
videos for technical enablement
to build a sustainable
and successful business
over the long term and solve
your toughest challenges
with Google's proven technology
and multifaceted partnership.
Introducing Technical
Guides for Startups.
JOLENE TEO: This
series is especially
designed to help
startups and beginners,
and to also at the
same time, understand
how other startups are
leveraging our products
and solutions.
This series is
especially catered
to match your startup's
stage of growth,
as well as product and
program engagement.
JEEVANA HEGDE: We will have
multiple video series focusing
on different stages for every
step of your startup journey,
all the way from start,
where we will work
on helping beginners and
early stage startups which
are in the pretrial
phase to build, deploy,
and manage new applications
on Google Cloud
from start to finish.
This can be for everyone just
starting out and validating
the minimum viable product.
JOLENE TEO: And
moving on to build,
this is where we'll be working
with startups that have already
launched on Google Cloud
to scale and optimize
their existing
deployments in order
to reach their target audience.
JEEVANA HEGDE: And finally,
grow, where we help startups
that are looking to grow
and achieve planet scale
deployments on Google Cloud.
So this can be leveraged
for scale ups growing
to meet the needs of new
customers and markets.
JOLENE TEO: And in this series,
which is the start series,
as you probably guessed by now,
is to help early stage startups
to get started on Google Cloud.
Through this series, we
will be navigating together
through a series of
topics on Google Cloud.
And to kick off, as
you can see, this
is our launch video
to show you and let
you know what you can expect in
the following videos to come.
JEEVANA HEGDE: In
our next video,
we will be sharing on how you
can get started on Google Cloud
and also go over the
Google Cloud Console.
JOLENE TEO:
Following that, we'll
be looking into application,
deployment, as well as
the Google Kubernetes Engine.
JEEVANA HEGDE:
Following that, we
shall do a fresh deployment,
where we will show you
how you can build on
Google Compute Engine,
and further manage
networking configurations,
and explore the
database configurations
for the same
application, just so you
know how the entire flow for
a single application works.
JOLENE TEO: Once we
are done with that,
we'll then take a
look into how Firebase
can help you to build, improve,
and grow your applications.
And then from there,
we'll then navigate
through the landscape of CI/CD
deployments with Google Cloud.
JEEVANA HEGDE: We will also
go over loading, monitoring
and more for your
deployed application
using Cloud Operations.
And finally, look into
billing and cost optimization,
as well as learn about
the support packages.
And that will be the
wrap up of start series.
And from there, we will
move on to build and grow.
JOLENE TEO: And so, for our very
next stop, in our second video,
Getting Started on
Google Cloud, we
will be showing
you how you can get
started by first creating
an account, an organization,
and project.
JEEVANA HEGDE: We will also
run through the Google Cloud
Console platform and cover how
you can build your security
foundation on Google Cloud with
identity and access management
for your resources.
So stay tuned as we
begin this journey.
And we'll be working
alongside you
to explore concepts, step by
step guides, and use cases,
across industries.
JOLENE TEO: And that is a wrap.
Please do subscribe to
this YouTube channel
to stay up to date.
And don't forget to
click on the bell icon
to receive notifications
each time we post
a new video in this series.
We hope that you are as
excited as we are to embark
on this journey together.
And so hang tight, and we'll--
JEEVANA HEGDE: --see
you, on the other side.
[MUSIC PLAYING]